So, I grew up in southern Indiana in the late nineteen-sixties to overprotective parents.
to overprotective parents. We were a barely middle class family living in a not
a not so great neighborhood. But my parents wanted the best for me and better than what was in the world around me, so
around me.  So, to that end I lead a very sheltered life.
life. I only went to home school and church. Uh, at the age of five I began piano lessons
began piano lessons, I could go there. But I could not play with any of the kids in my neighborhood I could only play in the backyard
play in the backyard with my little sister.  Now my
Now my mother was a beautiful and elegant woman.  She was a bit of a fashionista.  She was the kind of lady that would
of lady that would get dressed up to go to the mailbox.  And she dressed
And she dressed in the style of Jackie O.  Now, my father was an incredible
an incredible, charismatic person. He had an upbeat attitude, and a can-do kind of
do kind of spirit.  And he dressed, and moved, and looked like Sidney Poitier
Poitier, and I was the center of his universe as he was mine.  When I
When I was a little girl as a toddler, I would, he would dress me up, and go, and I'd go with him on errand day and he would
he would be obnoxious with a camera.  He would get total strangers to take
to take pictures of us together.  And then he would regale them with tales of my brilliance as a three-year-old
three-year-old.  So, when I got a
when I got a little older I was about eight-years-old. I became more of a, uh,
a, uh, the son that my father never had.  And I spent a lot of time in his study, and we had
and we had one of those studies like you saw in the movies.  He had a floor to ceiling bookcase with the entire
entire Encyclopedia Britannica.  And he had a big, oak desk with clawed feet,
and I used to sit in his lap. And he would teach me how to write with a fountain pen.
My father had the belief
that one of the things that you needed to make your way in the world was
a distinctive and impressive signature. So he taught me how to copy his
his signature with a fountain pen and how to create one of my own, a
unique signature of my own.
And that's one of the best shared moments that I have. With my father. That. And the 1976
Summer Olympics.
Olympics. Because first of all it was our first world event together, and for the first
time in Olympic history something had happened that it never happened before. An athlete was
awarded a score of a perfect ten, and it was given to Nadia Comaneci at the
age of sixteen for her impressive and flawless gymnastics routine.
And my father explained to me how difficult that was because
the athletes were rated on two different scales. They got a rating for artistic impression
and one for technical merit,
and those were averaged out together to get a perfect score so she had to get a ten
on both, both ratings, in order to come up with a perfect 10 for a final score.
And when I learned this I became obsessed with the Olympic rating
scale. I began reading everything in my life on the rating scale. My
dad's pancake flipping, his left hand turns into the driveway, my scales and
arpeggios I could play.
This thing took over my life. So in 1979 I turned 13,
and two very important things happened.
First of all I got a summer job, and, two, I began to notice
boys. Now this summer job was an early work program because my parents were, like, overachievers,
and they wanted me to get started on my job experience and character references. So it was
about me and about 19 other 13 year olds. It was about a mix of ten boys, ten girls.
And our job was to detastle corn. Which
I'm sure you all know in Iowa. [groans and laughter] Thank you.
Hellacious, hellacious, job, OK,
in the burning hot sun and, like, you know, high mud
and so like. After the first week of this most of the girls cut out, so it was only, like, me
and one other girl by the end of the week. So I instantly became the center of attention.
And the person, one person who became the center of my attention was
Robert Buster Townsend
the 3rd. And
Buster, Buster was delicious.
He was. He was a fair skin, freckle-faced black boy
and he had an athletic build. And he was not the brightest bulb on the tree,
but I did not care because he could have read a grocery list, and I was mesmerized.
So, about a week of,
like, fishing around with each other and flirting we finally decided that we liked each
other and that's when Buster first made the attempt to kiss me.
Now, I have not had the birds and the bees speech with my parents yet,
and the only things I knew about sex I had gleaned from the Harlequin romance novels
that my spinster cousin had left over at my grandma's
house. And so the things that I got out of them were this. Was first
of all that all intimate relationships began with a kiss and,
according to the writing, all of these women who got this kiss were somehow
forever changed.
Like the, the writing would get all flowery, a-and you
wouldn't know what was going on but that's only thing you could figure out. So the only thing that I could
parallel this with, the only other stories like a parallel this with, in my own life, that I knew about, were
Dr. Jekyll and Mr.
Hyde and Adam and Eve in the Garden of Eden. Those are the only stories I knew where
people started out one way and something happened and they were forever changed. So
I figured that if I started to, if I had Buster kiss me, then something I was going
to transform in some way that I could not control, so I wouldn't let him kiss me. So
we went through this whole process
where we would you know after work we'd hang out in a parking lot and hold hands and flirt. And he'd try to kiss me and, you know,
I wouldn't let him kiss me.
So one day we're holding hands and my father pulls up in the parking lot kind of
early, so I go skipping off and I get in the car, and I immediately noticed that
my dad is really angry and really silent. I could tell something
is going on, because he's staring straight out the windshield and he's not looking at me
and he's gripping the steering wheel. And so I look over kind of nervous and I say,
"Dad, is there something wrong?" And my dad erupts into
what sounds to me like
this loud long lion roar of a
monologue, "I SAW YOU TALKING TO THESE BOYS.
I SAW YOU HOLDING HANDS WITH THESE BOYS." And
he pulls out like these big SAT words "Boys are like licentious
and nefarious CREATURES." And so now,
I am both terrified
and amazed. So he doesn't speak to me
for the rest of, you know, the rest of the evening. And so we get back in the car, and he's taken me to work the
next day, and he's giving me a less vocal rendition of the licentious and
nefarious speech, but
instead of me, you know, being frightened, I'm starting to get angry. And I'm
getting more and more angry to the point where I'm-- by the time we get there, I'm kind of pissed off.
So I look at him when I get out of the car, and I slam the car door. And I turn around, and I,
that's when I made the decision that, I am going to let Buster kiss me, come what may.
I didn't care, didn't care.
So now here it is, after work,
and I'm standing in the parking lot, and I let Buster kiss me.
And can I tell you, it was the most amazing thing. It was delicious, okay?
When our lips met. It was like somewhere in
my mind. A door swung open to a room full
of incredible sensations, And that room, I realized
was called pleasure.
And it was like a medium-long kiss, but
when it was over, Busters parents were there, and so h-he, kind of, you know,
disappeared. And I'm standing there basking in the glow of this kiss, and
I realize that this is a very monumental moment in my life.
One that needs to be rated. So I quickly, [laughter]
It does, it does! So I immediately start to rate this kiss, I'm considering its artisitic
impression and the technical merit. So
I decided, I did, I decided
to give Buster a 9.7 for technical
merit, and an 8.8 for artistic impression for combined score of about
9.3. Which I thought was good because it left room for improvement, but it was a
pretty good kiss.
[laughter and applause]
So
I had settled all of that in my mind, and then I looked up
and realized that I was the only kid left in the parking lot. So I
just started the walk home because that's what you did in the 1970s, we didn't have cell phones you can let your
kids just kind of wander
home. So now, I'm walking home, and I'm thinking
about the consequences of this kiss because now I'm going to be forever changed.
So I'm checking myself to see if there's any kind of transformation is going to take place, and
I'm developing contingency plans in my head in case my behavior changes and
I can't control it. So, this is where my head is that, and finally when I get to
the door of
my house, before I can barely even knock on the door, my mother opens the door and she says, "I
need you to help me with your father."
And so I go into the living room, and I look at my father is lying in the fetal
position on the couch, and he's shaking
violently. And we had to take him to the hospital.
So we get him, um, registered in emergency, and it takes about an hour and a
half and we filled out paperwork
And my father comes back and he's lying stretched out on a gurney, and he's not quite shaking as much,
but he's in a hospital gown, and, I look at him, and his eyes are
very wide they kind of remind me of the look that the bunny rabbits
have that graze in our backyard. And it was the first time that I saw my
father looking so frail, and I said, "Dad are you alright?"
And with that classic smile and that can-do spirit he didn't say anything but he sort of
just smiled and nodded.
And as they wheeled him away on the gurney my father's
downward spiral begins as he spends thirty days in I.C.U. in
a coma and finally
dies. And
that's when my world began to implode, because from that day,
I never went back to that job. I never saw Buster again.
And I never had time to process any of
this, because I was too busy trying to share her household responsibilities with my mother
while trying to keep up with the expectations of my
father. And it doesn't even really hit me until one day, I'm 29 years
old, and I'm on my lunch break and I'm standing in an open air
parking garage. And the smell of corn comes wafting in
over the whole Ohio River and it comes back to me and I start to
cry. Because I remember that the last real
interaction that I had with my father was when I slammed the car
door. And it didn't make me feel very good, I started to feel very guilty.
But then
the corn also brought back, the small the corn brought back, the memory of
that delicious kiss.
kiss.
9.7 for technical merit. And
8.8 for artistic impression. And
even kisses today have a
very complex emotional feeling that it brings up inside of me
of nostalgia and guilt and pleasure. And it
took me a very, very long time, but later what I realized
was this.
this. Is that no kiss in the world could ever
taint or destroy my father's love for me or his legacy
that lives in me of his indomitable
spirit, his can-do attitude, and his kick-
ass signature. Thank you.
Thank you. You'll.